بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
يقول الله تعالى يا ايها الذين امنوا
اجتنبوا كثيرا من الظن ان بعض الظن اثم
ولا تجسسوا ولا يغتب بعضكم بعضا
يحب احدكم ان ياكل لحم اخيه ميتا فكرهتموه
واتقوا الله ان الله تواب رحيم
قدر الله سبحانه وتعالى النهي بقوله يا
ايها الذين امنوا
وقد سبق الكلام على هذا النداء المبارك
الحافل الذي تحته من المعاني ما تحته
يقول تعالى اجتنبوا اجتنبوا
وهذه من اشد الفاظ النهي هذه الصيغه من
اشد الفاظ النهي في كتاب الله وفي سنه
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم شرعا
الاجتناب
ومن اشد
صيغ النهي فان الله سبحانه وتعالى في
الاصل قد ينهى
بايسر واوضح صيغ النهي بان
ياتي
بالفعل المضارع
مع لا الناهيه لا تفعل لا تفعل هذا اوضح
انواع النهي
ولكن الله سبحانه وتعالى كثيرا ما يعدل عن
هذا الاسلوب الى اسلوب اخر
لمعان كثيره يريد ان يحمل الايه
فمثلا قد ياتي النهي
قد ياتي النهي في صيغه الخبر
هذا كثيرا في القران قد ياتي النهي
صيغه الخبر يعني يكون هو خبر
ظاهرا لكنه خبر اريد به
اريد به انشاء يعني اريد به
النهي مثل قول الله تعالى
ان يكن منكم عشرون صابرون يغلبوا مئتين
اظن خبر صح ولا لا اذا كان منكم عشرين
صابرين مؤمنين
فان الله ضامن لكم
الغلبه على 200
من الذين كفروا بانهم قوم لا يفقوا
لكن
هذا خبر
والحقيقه اريد به النهي او الامر
كانه قال
ان كنتم عشرين
واجهكم
مئتان فان الفرار لا يجوز
فكانوا 250 مئتين وعشرين ماشي فرار يجوز
في هذه الحال ثم نسخ الله ذلك بايش الذي
بعده
يعني الله عز وجل يخبرنا ان يكن منكم
عشرون صابرون يغلبوا 200 وبعدين في الايه
اللي بعدها ما قال الان خفف الله عنكم
وعلم ان فيكم ضعفا فانكم منكم مئه صابره
يغلب 200 طيب نسخ الكلام هذا اسم نسخ رفع
الحكم السابق بحكم لاحق وهذا لا يكون في
الاخبار هذا لا يكون الا فيه
احكام مش ممكن ان الله تعالى يخبرنا
بنعم ثم ياتي خبر بعده ويقول لا وهذا
الخبر نفس
وهذا في نفس الامر هذا لا يكون الا في
الاوامر اما في الاخبار فلا يجوز النسخ
فالمقصود هنا
النهي لكن جاء النهي في ماذا في صيغه
الخبر لماذا لاسباب كثيره
كان من الممكن ان يقول الله ان كنتم
فلا تفر من مئتين والكلام صار اسهل وايسر
وواضح لكن عدل الله سبحانه وتعالى عن هذا
الى اسلوب اخر
لزياده تثبيت القلوب كان الله تعالى يقول
لا تفر ولكم الضمان مني انه سيكون كذا
وكذا
فهو اخبر بصيغه الخبر
وقد ياتي النهي او الامر في صيغه الخبر
لاسباب اخرى مثل قول الله سبحانه وتعالى
والمطلقات يتربصن بانفسهن ثلاثه قروء
هذا ليس امرا هذا خبر
لكنه امر في صيغه الخبر لماذا
للدلاله على ثبوت هذا الحكم وكانه معروف
للمسلمين ولغير المسلمين
هذا امر لا يتجاوز معروف اسال اي واحد
بخبرك بهذا الخبر
فهذا اشد في النهي من مجرد قوله
المراه تتربص ثلاثه قروء ان طلقت
فهذا اسلوب ياتي في القران اساليب كثيره
متنوعه
الحكم قد يكون واحد لكن درجه الحكم شده
الحكم شده الدليل شده الاسلوب يختلف
الله عز وجل يقول من صيغ ومن الفاظ النهي
الصريحه اجتنبوا
اجتنبوا
هذا اشد من مجرد النهي
اشد من ان يقول الله لا تفعل او لا تفعلوا
فان هذا فيه
صيغه الفعل
بالاجتناب ما هو الاجتناب اصل الاجتناب من
جنب الجيم والنون والباء
فاذا قال الله اجتنب كانه يقول كن في
جانبا
مضادا لجانب هذا الامر الذي نهيتكم عنه لا
تقرب هذا مثله
لا تقرب
هو بين
الاجتناب والنهي الصريح يعني عنا درجات
اظهر وايسر الفاظ النهي لا تفعل وبعدين
عنا ايش لا تقرب وبعدين عنا اجتنب يعني
يكون في جانب مضاد لهذا الجانب وبعدين
تاتي الفاظ اخرى لا يفعل هذا الا الكافرون
مثلا لا يفعل هذا الا المشركون
المنافقون يفعل كيت وكيت هذه كلها اساليب
اساليب ردع لا تفعل هذا الشيء
ومن هذه الاساليب ايضا الابتداء بنداء
الايمان يا ايها الذين امنوا
فعندنا النداء بالايمان هذا يدل على وجوب
هذا
الاجتلاب وعندنا ايضا لفظ اجتنبوا
اجتنبوا من اشد الفاظ النهي
يعني كن في جانب
مختلف
عن جانب هذا الفعل
ليس لا تقرب هذا الفعل بل اجتنب هذا الفعل
ومن
الاجتناب شرعا
الابتعاد عن اصحاب هذا الفعل
ماشي يعني مثلا الله عز وجل يقول
من عمل الشيطان
فاجتنبوه لعلكم تفلحون
في الخمر والميسر
نهى الله عز وجل عن الخمر
وقال فاجتنبوه
هذا المعنى
ماذا فهم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من هذا
اللفظ
فاجتنبوا
لننظر في السنه لان السنه ما هي في
الحقيقه
غالب السنه غالب كلام الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم وفعل الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
غالبوا
وماذا
هو فهمه الموفق للقران غالبه
طبعا السنه على ثلاثه احوال مع القران
اما ان يقول الرسول تماما ما في القران
بالضبط او
يزيد في التفاصيل
مما اجمله القران او ياتي بحكم مستقل ليس
مذكورا في القران وهذا نادر جدا لكنه
موجود
موجوده احكام موجوده بس في السنه
ولا
يحاجنا احد بقوله
اين هو في القران لا اشياء كثيره غير
موجوده في القران اتفق المسلمون على على
تحريم هذه الامور او على وجوب هذه الامور
اشياء كثيره
مثل
اكل السبع
اكل السباع هل يجوز محرم باجماع العلماء
هذا النهي في القران ليس في القران موجود
في السنه
وايضا
الطير الذي له مخلب مفترس هل هذا محرم في
القران ليس له ذكر في التحريم في القران
لكنه محرم في السنه وكذلك الحمار الاهلي
هل هو محرم في القران ليس محرما في القران
محرم في السنه
لكن غالب السنه
هذه الاحكام التي ذكرنا نادره احنا بنمثل
اذا نظرنا الى غالب السنه وفهمنا القران
صح
فاننا نجد ان السنه
عباره عن فهم الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
للقران
الله عز وجل يقول
لتحكم بين الناس بما اراك الله
ايش يعني اراك الله يعني وفقك
اليه من جراء البصيره الطاهره
المستنيره
فيريه الله سبحانه وتعالى الحق لذلك
فانك لا تكاد تجد حكما في السنه
الا وله
ذكر في القران
او
في اماء
فالقران اليه او اجمال يدخل فيه وهكذا
فقول
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
يعلمنا كثيرا عن مراد الله بالقران
فمثلا هذه اللفظه اجتنبوا
لننظر ماذا فهم الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
من هذه اللفظه
ما هو مقتضى هذا النهي
فقال صلى الله عليه وسلم
في القران في الخمر انما الخمر والميسر
والانصاب والازلام ريجيسون من عمل الشيطان
فاجتنبوه لعلكم تفلحون
فماذا فهم من اجتنبوه
قال لعن الله في الخمر عشرا
حامل الخمر وصانع الخمر وعاصر الخمر
ومعتصرها والمحمول اليه وباعي وبائعه واكل
ثمنه وشاربه في الاخر
هذا كله داخل فيه مجمل قوله ماذا
اجتنبوه
عندنا امثله اخرى
جاء في
المسند مسند الامام احمد
ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
من كان يؤمن بالله واليوم الاخر فلا يجلس
على مائده
يشرب عليها الخمر
ايش يعني هذا الكلام
يعني انت ما بتشرب لكن جالس بتوكل مع ناس
تؤكلهم
وهم يشربون الخمر انت لا تشرب
هل هذا يجوز
ويقول الذي يؤمن بالله واليوم الاخر ما
يفعل هذا
من اين هذا
غالب الظن انه من فاجتنبوه
يعني اجتنب ليس فقط الفعل اجتنب اي شيء
يؤدي الى هذا الفعل او يصون هذا الفعل او
يوصل اليه او يكون وسيله الي واجتنب اصحاب
هذا الفعل
وهذا كله يفهم وصحيح
في قوله
اجتنبوا كثيرا من الظن
ان بعض الظن اثم
كيف الانسان يجتنب كثيرا من الظن اذا فقط
مجرد بعض الظن اثم
لاحظوا اللفظ يعني
اجتني كثيرا من الظن
فان بعض الظن اثم
هذا ما يسمى في
ماذا نسميه نسميه احتياط صح ولا لا
يعني ثم اشياء هي اثم في الظن
ماشي مقطوع بها هذا اثم
وثم اشياء
مشتبها
لا يعلمها فما اشياء مجتبها لا يعلمها
كثير من الناس
فهي ماذا مشبوهه
من الظنون
فماذا يكون امر من اشتبه عليه
المحرم
والذي وحل له عليه ان
يجتنب ماذا الشبهات
اتقي الشبهات
قال ان الحلال بين وان الحرام بين وبينهما
امور مشتبهات لا يعلمهن كثير من الناس فمن
اتقى الشبهات فقد استبرا لدين وعرضه ايش
هذا يعني تقوى الشبهات يتقي الانسان
الشبهات يعني يحتاط لدينه هذا هذا هو
اتقاء الشبهات الاحتياط
هذا نفس هذا
ايش يعني الاحتياط يعني الامر
غير واضح
فانا اغلب جانب
الحذر واغلب جانب براءه الذمه على ماذا
لان دفع دفع المدار المفاسد مقدم على جلب
المصالح
فانا
ابقى على اصل براءه الذمه
فان الله تعالى سيسالك لما فعلت
ولن يسالك لماذا لم تفعل يعني في الامور
المانهي عنها
فانك ستسال لما فعلت
لكن الامور المباحه لن تسال لماذا لم تفعل
هذا اليك
وادم عليه السلام
لم يساله الله لما اكلت ما اكلت وانما
ساله لمن تهكت هذه الحرمه هذه المحرمه من
الماكل لما فعلت
فهذا هو الذي هو مسؤول عنه الانسان
اذا فهمنا هذا فهمنا ان كلمه اجتنبوا
من اشد الفاظ النهي
وهذا وهذا اللفظ اجتنب يدل على التحريم
باجماع اهل العلم
ثم ياتي اناس مفتونون
قد غم الله عليهم قلوبهم
ولبس عليهم الشيطان دينهم
فقالوا ليس ظاهرا التحريم للخمر في القران
هكذا يقولون مش واضح انه الخمر محرم في
القران
اللي حرام في القران
انه الواحد يسكر وقت الصلاه
لكن غير هيك مش واضح
وبعدين ياتي يتفلس
يتفلسف يجيب لك قصه من هان وقصه من هان
ونادره من هان ويربط لك اياهن كلهن في
بعضهم
والجاهل بيغتار بكل سبحانه شوف
مع انه صاحب العلم صاحب الحته الفطره
السليمه يعرف هذا كله نفخ
هذا نفخ الشيطان ماذا اعطى الله الشيطان
هل اعطاه تغيير
الحقائق ليس له تبديل الحقائق صح ولا لا
الشيطان له اشي واحد ما هو
التزيين
لازينن لهم
بس
بس التزيين ما لوش غير هيك
وكيف التزيين
بخوفك من الشيء الفاضي الشيء اللي هو فارغ
بنفخه
هولوا في ذهنك
والشيء الكبير
الذي هو عظيم يلفت نظرك عنه ويصوره اليك
وكانه لا شيء
وهلم جره والامثله كثيره
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كان يستعيذ
بالله
من
الشيطان الرجيم من همسه ونفخه ونفثه
كان يستعيد بالله من نفخ الشيطان
وهذا من نفخ الشيطان
فهؤلاء
الفتانون الجاهلون الذين
اشتروا
وتجراوا على
نار جهنم والعياذ بالله
فانهم ياتون
القران
ويفهمون القران
طبقا
لما يملي عليهم هواهم
فياتون باشياء من هذه الاشياء
التشكيك تشكيك الناس في تحريم الخمر
في تحريم الخمر
وبعدين ياتوك بعجائب يعني مثلا
الله عز وجل
نجا عاصر الخمر
يعني يوسف قصه يوسف
دخل معه السجن فتيان
الخباز المسكين انصلب واما عاصم الخمر
فخرج عصا الخمر
ممكن هذا نبني عليه اذا كنت كان هذا
التفكير سليم
اذا الخمر ليس فقط مباحا بل هو مبارك بنجي
من السجن كمان
يعني يعني يجعل نيتك عصر الخمر
ولا تجعل نيتك
انك تخبص يعني الخبز حرام يعني بدك تكمل
المشوار اذا
بهذا الاسلوب
هذا كلام لا يقوله اصحاب العلم
واصحاب الخوف من الله وانما يقوله الذين
يريدون ان يفرقوا بين الله ورسله
ويقولون نؤمن ببعضهم ونكفر ببعض
فياتي
احدهم فيقول
لعامه المسلمين
بيننا وبينكم القران فما وجدنا فيه من
حلال استحللناه وما وجدنا فيه من حراما
حرمنا هذه مقوله صحيحه ام غير صحيحه
هذه مقوله
ما يعبر عنها العلماء فيقولون حق اريد به
باطل
صحيح نحن نحرم ما في القران ونحل ما في
القران لكن هم يريدون باطلا بهذه المقوله
فهم يقولون المقصود فقط في القران اما
السنه فلا نلتفت اليها النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
حذرنا من اولئك فقال
لا الفينا وقال يوشك
رجل شبعان
مملوء البطن
متكئ على اريكته
ياتيه الامر من اوامري او نهي
مما نهيت عنه فيقول بيننا وبينكم القران
فما وجدنا فيه من حلال استحللناه وما
وجدنا فيه من حرام حرمناه
قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الا اني
اوتيت القران ومثله معه
فهؤلاء قالوا اجتنب ليس هذا ناهيا شو يعني
اجتنب وهذا جهل العميق يعني
جهل بحير صراحه
وزمن بحير يعني
اجتنب اشد من مجرد التحريم كما ذكرنا
اجتنب يعني كن في جانب مضاد
واذا كان هذا في صف فكن في صف مضاد
واجتنبه وابتعد عن اهله كمان ولا تقربه كل
هذه المعاني في معنى اجتنب
يقول كثيرا من الظن ان بعض الظن اثم
فنحن نجتنب الكثير لان الظن منه ما سيكون
واضحا بينا حله ومنه ما هو واضح بين
تحريمه ومنه ما هو مشتبه على كثير من
الناس فماذا نصنع نغلب جانب
براءه الذمه
ونغلب التحضير على عباره الاصوليين من اجل
السلامه من اجل براءه الذمه
فلا نظن الا ما كان
واضحا بينا صلاحه
واستحسانه عند الله واما ما كان خبيثا فمن
باب اولى
وما كان مشكوكا فيه فهذا يجتنب كذلك لانه
من الشبهات والشبهات
ونحن ندرا الشبهات ندره ندرا
الاحكام
والحدود بالشبهات كما هو معروف
في
اصول الاسلام ان شاء الله نكمل هذا المعنى
غدا باذن الله وجزاكم الله خيرا والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد بارك
الله